a lot of goals being given out tonight
but Hollywood will never run out of it
as long as we have treasures like our
next two stars
he made his sensational screen debut as
golden boy and will never forget his
leading lady whose performances are
never less than 24 karat the golden boy
and his golden girl are together again
tonight William Holden and Barbara
Stanwyck
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before Barbara and I present this next
award I'd like to say thirty-nine years
ago this month we were working in a film
together called Golden Boy I wasn't
going well because I was going to be
replaced but due to this lovely human
being and her interest in understanding
and her professional integrity and her
encouragement and above all her
generosity I'm here tonight oh yeah
Barbara and I are pleased to give the
sound award because by coincidence this
is not only the Academy's 50th
anniversary it's also the 50th birthday
of sound talking pictures when Al Jolson
said you ain't heard nothing yet he
anticipated one of the most famous
billboards in our moving picture history
Garbo speaks Greta Garbo is one of the
silent stars who survived the advent of
sound and that deep throaty voice
perfectly complemented bed exquisite
face and thanks to sound movies our
voice still thrills us the nominations
for accomplishments achieved in sound
are Robert Knudsen Robert J glass Don
McDougald
Dougal and Jean s contem esse for Close
Encounters of the Third Kind Walter Goss
dick Alexander Tom Beckett and Robin
Gregory for the deep Robert Knudsen
Robert J glass Richard Tyler and Jean
Louie do com4 sorcerer
Don MacDougall ray West Bob Minkler and
Derek ball for Star Wars
[Music]
Theodore Soderbergh Paul wells douglas o
williams and Jerry Jost for the turning
point and here my golden boy you read it
the winners are Don Dougal ray West Bob
McClure and Derrick balls
[Applause]
and Bob
[Music]
[Applause]
this is really an honor and buzzy was
right your hands do get wet I'd
certainly like to thank George and Gary
for all they've done for us they gave us
an opportunity I must also thank Bob
lifts a gentleman who helped us very
much Steve Katz another one all the
wonderful mixers who aided us in the
early stages of our work and all of you
thank you very much
deeply grateful thank you
[Music]
to present the Oscars to the winners of
this year's special visual effects
here's the lady who once shared my
gondola in the canal is a paramount Joan
Fontaine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well you realize this is about the first
time we've acted together since Casanova
yeah well being at your side fair lady
has never worked oh sweet Robin age is
not with it nor custom stage or infinite
gallantry and Donny and Marie think
they're cute all right for you there are
two nominations for our best achievement
in special visual effects this 50th
anniversary year and they are ROI of
August Douglas Trumbull Matthew your
cinch and Gregory G and Richard usage
for Close Encounters of the Third Kind
John says John Dykstra Richard Edlund
grant McCune and Robert black for Star
Wars
the winners are John steers John dice
Richard Edlund
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody's gonna say something oh so
sorry yeah well ladies and gentlemen
this is a fantastic feeling to be up
here with with these guys fantastic guys
wonderful American Crew and please don't
forget the British guys that work with
me just make possible be here and thank
you Gary and George fantastic thank you
[Applause]
mr. and mr. Lucas
technicians who made it all possible
because that wasn't them on a soundstage
and I'd also like to thank Doug Trumbull
who started me in this business thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
in the past who made our statements
possible particular bill reinholt Jack
Caldwell and Paul or pay from the Star
Wars production I'd like to thank Paul
Roth Jamie short John Dykstra George
Lucas and Gary Kurtz
this is ours thank you
you